[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm link and I read this week at the
roundtable of dim lighting we are
exploring the question why am i Rhett
growing out my hair and beard why are
you growing out your hair and beard hair
and beard you're growing out your hair
and beard hair and beard I'm a hair and
beard I'll be a different thing and be
beard shaped like a heron which is a
bird well you know what it is starting
to assume the shape of something that
can it it's it's curling forward in the
front and if someone's like there's a
beak it could be from a oh I would say
okay I'm listening I'm on board for this
hold on so I'm bored for you talking
about oh you just cut your Eurasian hair
you cut yourself short in your hair and
you said okay I'm on board
why are we talking like this today we're
talking very stuck up toho stuck out
duck now is it are you tease me I'm on
board but they may not be so what is it
you mean I say Asst teasing don't tease
my hair there's there's something to
this like okay well as rumblings of
reasons so apparently there's enough to
talk about I mean this may be an
announcement to you but yes the plan is
to grow my hair and my beard out and I
have a reason I want to use I knew you
were gonna do it this is not news but I
heard some rumblings of the specifics
and it may not seem like the kind of
thing that warrants a conversation on
your biscuits but you know I think we've
demonstrated that it doesn't take much
to warn a conversation on your biscuits
but is there is it is there something to
this like is this gonna go somewhere
this conversation I'm like I certainly
hope so for the sake of the
entertainment of the people you're not
really selling it well like I'm looking
for a teaser like yes and what I'm
really gonna talk I have a deeply
personal reason that I'm doing it there
it is ever a tease you have a deep so it
it's not it's not a shallow thing
there's a deep there could be shallow
elements to it as well we'll explore all
that okay alright but it started in a
deeply personal place all right I
I hereby
commit to being actively engaged in
ripping you to shreds but also
supporting you emotionally okay that's
interesting this conference okay before
we get into your hair and beard I can't
figure out if this is something to
celebrate because it it might come
across as bragging and bragging dad I'm
trying to figure out how a brag about
this but I got a new car hey this is not
a normal thing for you I don't I'm
coming yeah like I've been driving this
Scion xB that we bought together how
many years ago like you've you've been
through a number of cars and I've just
been driving this Scion xB when we first
just to step back a little bit when we
don't when it was when we first moved to
LA we we towed my family minivan behind
a u-haul truck and then you you took
over the lease from somebody in Santa
Monica fun fact
life tip I didn't know this was a thing
but if you need a car for a short period
of time and I needed a car for six
months because we were saying we were we
were gonna be here for six months in
furnished apartments right we didn't
move all of our stuff you can actually
left a car back in North Carolina I
guess we added two of them you can take
over someone else's lease and there are
different websites where you can do it
so it's much cheaper than renting a car
you don't want to rent a car for six
months and if you're in a situation like
I was and couldn't borrow a car cuz I
was going to a new place where I didn't
know anybody you can take over
somebody's lease I did it was a Saturn
oh well in time I drove a Saturn and
then Saturn just quit making cars I went
with you to pick it up Culver City so
that I drove you there cuz uber wasn't
really popping yet no it wasn't Culver
City it was all the way it was at the
beach almost it was like Cerritos
something and we if I remember correctly
we like went into this guy's apartment
it's like if you're going Craigslist to
buy like a bike or something
you like me to guide his apartment you
buy it but for you it was taken over the
lease of a car it felt a little wind I
was like I don't know if I actually took
it over I just got the keys and drove
away but your was paper working and cash
involved yeah but it was all doll the
paperwork was with the bank and then our
second car when he when we settled into
living here
we leased a Ford Fusion Fuller diffusion
with as a company car which I drove and
then I would I would come to your house
because we worked in your backyard well
between the two fan have a car between
the two families
we had three cars total so y'all had a
minivan
we had an SUV and that was what Jesse
and Christy drove because they needed to
take the children and then we shared a
car we shared a car because I didn't
have a commute right and then we started
that for a good while and then we bought
speaking of cash we bought the Scion
because that's the car that you had back
in North Carolina and you liked it
because it was it had storage capacity
and it was it works actually for a tall
person so you could sit up still its
ions one of the best cars for a tall
person and we had this idea to buy it in
cash like we had this vision of taking
out the cash well I think that when
people said you buy a car in cash
we literally thought that meant that you
took a stack of cash into the dealership
well and then it just really means you
just don't finance it yeah it does means
you like get a cashier's check but we
literally took a stack I'm sure with
this story yeah we took a cash okay how
much money how much money desire cost
it was $18,000 okay and we put $18,000
in an envelope and water thought it was
gonna be a friend around we're gonna
have to get a duffel bag I don't know
like apparently that much I mean I could
have put it in my pocket and you would
have just thought I was excited yes not
is not that much much because it's if
you get a thousand-dollar bill does it's
only 18 we didn't get those do exist but
I've never seen one we got got at
hundreds yes I got 18 no we got a
hundred and eighty one hundred hundred
dollar bills yeah you don't need a
duffel bag for that and then we like
gave it to the guy and he like looked at
us kind of
because it's still like it's like once
taka it's I mean it's what rappers talk
about doing they got bands yeah I want
to do it more often
he had to take the money and put it in a
counter yeah to twice it account it
twice because you know a lot of cash so
I've been driving that thing around for
years I backed into somebody in a
Ralph's parking lot the bumpers all too
crapped out what taillights busted what
tail the taillights been busted for over
a year I've just been driving it you
know I mean it's got Bluetooth
connectivity to my phone I can listen to
music all you need bluetooth although I
read recently you should turn your
Bluetooth off because it is highly
susceptible to hacking here Eddy
breaches you should turn your airdrop
just turn your Bluetooth off unless you
are currently connecting to something
that requires bluetooth don't have it on
all the time because people be opening
up that mouth and taking advantage of
your Bluetooth oh really
your Bluetooth yeah yeah that's what I
heard you got a new car so I I finally
did it
hmm I got a new car and I've had in my
mind I want to get an electric vehicle
of course and I'm like you know what
this is this is my opportunity to
splurge you know I mean I've done some
things to splurge but this is the first
time I'm like this is like this is the
quintessence of splurge on myself oh
that's what I've done because you can
use it different I got an electric car a
test drove a Tesla and then I looked at
the price tag on that thing and I just
could not bring myself to do it yeah
especially the one you you were looking
at the what the X which is just I mean
because brand new I didn't want you to
get the car she said I needed to get the
SUV get the X so that like if the whole
family needed to go somewhere we could
still all technically get in it so I'm
like okay really that's the requirement
I think I do think that that's kind of
important yeah she talked me into that
because I test drove of a BMW the the i3
or three yeah it's like that look it
kind of looks like a bigger slightly
bigger visual burger bigger version of a
smart car he's the one that Katie Couric
and Bryant Gumble were in the commercial
making fun of themselves from talking
about the internet um in that campaign
not a lot of bells and whistles on that
BMW I'm like if I may get a BMW it needs
to have bells and freakin whistles it
did not have any and the reason was to
keep it lighter so it can have a greater
range and they're still trying to sell
you on and you put a little a little gas
engine in the back as a backup and I'm
like for some reason as anxious as I get
about things I wanted to fully commit to
an electric car I mean it's we also have
a gas power cough we go on like a trip
or camping or something so it's like
yeah I I don't have what they call range
anxiety well you have all other types of
things that but you've had the car for a
week I mean you don't know what kind of
anxiety you're gonna most people have it
and it keeps them from considering a
fully electric vehicle I thought range
anxiety is when you're in the car and
you look at it no meter but yes but it
starts with deciding if you're gonna
this is going okay car all right
I think I have that I looked at the Audi
e-tron you got a I had to sign up only
like a waiting list for like months and
months and months to get this thing so
they kind of tricked me into full
splurge because you go on and you you
configure your car and you're like you
place an order and they're like well you
can change this before we get it goes to
the plant to be made and so I'm like you
know what I'm going all the way and I
said yes to everything yeah I would
never went back on to the screen which I
you know you might call that the website
I call it the screen and like really say
you know what I'm not gonna get this
because it costed a little more and I'm
not gonna get this edition it's like the
first time I've ever said yes to
everything all the accessories for
anything yeah like I'm I'm usually the
one that's like yeah I'll get it but you
know I'm not gonna get this and this and
this next email I got they were shipping
the thing yeah and I was like too late
now I've I've talked my I've backed into
the splurge and again I just feel like
I'm I'm not I'm almost apologizing but
it's like because that I just have a
hard time spending money but uh so I got
this thing where are you
apologizing for the massaging seats it
has miss it's got seated massage and you
know what your seat gave me a massage I
don't know if you could tell by the look
on my face but I requested one by
pressing the buttons and I got one the
other day when I was it don't only has a
massage it's got like six different
types of massage yes she went up to the
salt shoulders I don't know if she the
deceit and deceit went up to the
shoulders the lower back mid-back and
then I put on the ventilation in your
nice leather perforated seats yes yeah
you do the bragging for good so I take
Lando to school yesterday of course I
usually am the one to take him to school
Christie takes Lillian Lincoln this high
school both in high school now a little
bit earlier hmm and um he all he got he
getting when he went around he got in
the front seat he said I'm getting in
the front seat and I was I looked at him
weird because like he insist on me
chauffeuring him to school like he would
always get in the back seat of the Scion
he would never get in the front seat
with me really most kids as soon as they
have the opportunity I know to the front
seat her up there so and I was like and
I don't exactly know why my theory was
when he got out of the front seat I'm
more visible and if any of the other
students can see it's me
he's like self-conscious about his dad
his dad being recognized as that guy
from the internet he hasn't outright
told me that but I think that was part
of it okay
he like he wants to slip out of the back
and put him in the trunk back into
school minifides
but he goes that I don't he's like I'm
getting in the front seat of course he's
in fourth grade now so maybe he's over
the old dad's famous he's realized it's
not who cares but what he really did was
he wanted that massager I'm like yeah
okay here's another benefit my son is
now riding beside me on the way to
school I can actually look at him a
little bit when we're we were driving it
then he so relaxed when he gets there
yeah he's just he's just like wake him
up so I'm where at school a puddle of
mud but I'll tell you this things got so
much stuff so many cameras so many
and blasts and whistles and alerts and
screens that I don't know where to look
yeah I mean you were backing out the
other day and I actually saw one view
was just a colonoscopy of myself yeah
how did the camera get there it's
actually I need to see a doctor
it's a colon cleanse it's a colonic
it's a clotting machine isn't so it's
not it's not doctor certified it's more
just like whoo science right kind of
yeah but it drains directly onto the
street it's not like I have to clean it
up arena I mean I don't know if you
noticed but I'm we're going to this I'm
driving well first of all I'm offering
to drive now yeah and then cuz I feel
like I feel like I'm just driving it's
for free it's just I feel like I'm I
never go to a gas station sure I plug it
into that thing when I get home but I
just feel like it's free fuel now the
sticker on the car said you saved like
twenty five hundred dollars over five
years in fuel cost I'm like man that's
that's depressingly low well because you
know the ironic thing is that the fuel
that you're using at home the the
electricity that you're using a home is
most likely generated by fossil fuels
but that is not a reason to not
transition to an electric car one of my
main motives that were in it for the
long haul higher mol baby yeah so I mean
there's zero emissions it's better for
it yes it's the right thing to do but it
is an expensive thing to do at this
point and you can't really do it to save
money but it's also a better driving
experience let me tell you man
I told Christie first time I got in the
same like well you're driving in the
future it just feels that way it's like
just I've never been in a car I've never
owned a car that had acceleration I'm
like accelerating for the first time in
a car just in it's exhilarating to
accelerate but let me tell you with so
much to look at and listen to and be
distracted by I I'm putting I'm putting
myself passengers and everyone around
the earth in some close calls you ran
you ran two red lights yesterday yes sir
red lights like I've ran two red lights
yesterday because it also takes you I
mean I'm looking at other thing it
already takes you a long time to get in
and go begin going cuz there's lots of
things that happen and then it takes you
a long time to get out of the car it's
been taking you I'd say an extra 45
seconds on top of you're already like
120 second route in well I don't even
know where the how to start it yet yeah
running red lights if I get it started I
mean like I almost hit a pedestrian and
here's the thing it's so quiet you know
they add a little sound oh you can leave
there's a little sound a it's a
futuristic sound when you pulled up in
my house with it for the first time it
was like look at that's the sound that
is not necessary for the operation of
the vehicle that is safety that is added
for safety and only I will and no and
coolness and in Reverse it makes it
sound so good I've never been I've never
heard it from the outset me drive it
I'll Drive it around you I'll Drive a
circle around and you can stand outside
and listen to it okay that's about as
far as I'll let you try I have it I did
let Lily Drive it I was pretty nervous
about that but yeah christy is not
driven it so yeah but you're gonna let
her I
I feel guilty about about doing it but
I'm also having the time of my life
behind the wheel yeah man
splurge yourself and I would think Audi
but it's not like I got a discount so
not a sponsor I mean you did buy it you
did order it directly after we attended
that Audi dinner that's true that was
one of the coolest experiences we've had
in our in terms of like the whole like
name-dropping kind of situation have we
dropped those names cuz let's do it
Don Cheadle yeah we had dinner and with
very small group of people and dot and
freaking Don Cheadle was there that's
all I got to say not he's not even I I
assumed he'd been nice but jovial guy so
nice like did you know that the first
adjective you would use to describe Don
Cheadle would be jovial well like dude
is jovial yeah yeah almost festive and
like not like crisp it feels like
Christmas around like very engaged with
whatever it is that everyone's talking
about Kumail Nanjiani we sat next to him
and we were talking about the each on
and he was like I don't quite I mean
it's basically just a station wagon and
I'm like yeah you're right I want I mean
it's not it's so in I I would have to
agree with that it's kind of its kind of
a practical thing which makes it it's
not like flashy
no it's got all the bells of Wilson you
also you went with like and it's I like
the color yeah it's a cool color but
it's cool because it's not cool you know
what I'm saying I never saw it on a car
when I ordered it was like oh you just
got it you got a tan beige station wagon
yeah I did you got a beige station where
no it's not really it's not it's a sexy
but it Lorient it looks very futuristic
and
and not as much as a Tesla though like
it's got a grill even though it doesn't
need it cuz so many people are driving a
Tesla you know yeah around here it's
just like basically just it looks like
another Audi it looks it looks like it's
not in a fully electronic vehicle
because of the grille and stuff like
that yeah until you guys well I I'm hell
muffler I'm happy for you
no mufflers that's my favorite part and
yeah I mean I got a new car you getting
a new hair the side effect of you
driving more though is that you don't
you're not great at carrying on a
conversation while driving so it makes
you know there's a little bit that's a
little bit of a bummer yes not fully you
know almost engaged it'll almost drive
itself yeah and then I can start talking
Brian I get in that mode once I figure
out how you use that okay we'll talk I
mean well if we have any more harrowing
or non harrowing experiences in your car
or not getting more massages well we'll
keep you updated on that need a massage
these need to be massaged general and
Kim I'll keep it to the car but first we
want to let you know that you should
head over to that new mythical dot-com
website and you should scroll first of
all it might just happen that you get a
little pop-up that invites you to
subscribe to receive the mythical
monthly newsletter where you get news
from us early access to discounts and a
lot more some recommendations etc or if
you don't see that pop up you can scroll
down to the bottom that would be a place
you can enter in your email address we
will make it worth your time this is not
a spammy situation we try to make each
one of those mythical monthly
newsletters useful something special
yeah also go to mythical Tom cup of ice
time mystical dot Tom mythical car like
this shirt long sleeve oath t got some
tricep printed action oh man my
shoulders hurting from be careful I
should get back in your car
[Laughter]
okay got an app I can I can start
cooling it off before I get in yeah
notice you did that he's got a valet
alert feature elee alert so if if I yeah
so if the valet take it farther if the
valet violate steals the car steals the
car I will know immediately if I turn
that on hmm
mythical dot store check it ok so
mythical duck I got to have it as a
mythical does soar I mean it'll redirect
it still no because mythical calms got
it all right so I I think I've only told
the largest group of people I told it I
think I told the mythical Society
members during one of the the monthly
vlogs we have like a monthly vlog over
there the mythical society and I said I
was good I basically said I was thinking
about didn't want to fully commit to
saying that I was growing my hair and my
beard out but I haven't talked about it
here I did say I would talk about why ok
so I at some point well first of all
like in most people you know my hair and
my beard have a certain cycle and most
people have sort of recognized like I
let my hair or my facial hair grow to
this point and then I get it cut
probably a lot of dudes are like on a
monthly schedule six weeks maybe and I
just got to the end of one of my cycles
and I was like I don't think I'm gonna
cut it and you're talking about the hair
at this point cuz the beard you would
trim more often in that the beard
I would trim more often but so the other
thing that I think that's thing that
coincided with this and was the
motivation for it the primary motivation
for it you
and I've I've given a little background
on this but in therapy sort of the main
thing that I am kind of focusing on his
style is yeah it's just looking better
know is and we're already talking about
therapy moving moving from the head to
the heart now okay scientifically
speaking what is there really a
difference I'm told what I'm talking
about is the principle of M of
embodiment and yeah we're we're in LA
now and we hang around folks who talk
about things like embodiment and do
things like embodiment workshops yeah
you can you can shake your head or what
you're whatever you do to those kinds of
things if you're not into it but I would
say that as I hopefully have
demonstrated and have talked about just
the idea of getting more in touch with
my feelings because I tend to be a super
heady person and actually if you ask me
what I'm feeling about something I will
tell you what I'm thinking about it and
this is a this is a pretty I would say
that this is a huge issue I know how to
tell you how I feel I just tell you how
I think you can alert you can john wayne
you can lead a horse okay you can lead a
horse to water but you can't make him
feel I think Jimmy Stewart and John
Wayne had a love child and that's what
you just comparison ated well that makes
me feel criticized so and you know the
interesting thing is and this is a thing
that I have discovered in in therapy is
I will cry very easily Feldman I was a
Feldman's wedding this past weekend I
cried at your wedding
congratulations film made wreck cry now
what kind of cry was it it was a it was
a it was a just a John Paul Jones for
those of you who watch bachelor in
paradise
it was just a heaving
it wasn't it wasn't anything like that
it was just my eyes welled up with tears
I don't believe that a tear dropped but
yours I got mad I got misty eyed you
were sad for Stacy when you when I
thought about what Stacy was gonna have
to endure for the next few decades yeah
and I will cry easily at a movie I will
cry I will cry at an emotional
commercial like everyone some others one
of those Superbowl commercials and it's
usually like about something like a
Dodge truck but it's the whole thing is
very like emotional and and it doesn't
take much to get to get the the
waterworks going for me but that
actually is not evidence of sensitivity
it's actually evidence of my tendency to
because all humans have to have some
kind of release of your emotions right
now typically for me it's gonna come out
with crying at things that there are no
I have no personal stakes in sorry to
say it Feldman I don't have any personal
stakes in your marriage I see your
marriage like a commercial that I'm just
viewing passively and so I'm very II it
doesn't take much to make me start
crying at that because you need to let
it out somehow I wonder what my release
is I think it might be just clenching my
butthole my butthole yeah you should
because Iran should see it there's not a
lot of release associated with clenching
but like yeah but that well there's
gotta be
that's the clinch so the what are you
what is the release for me I don't know
fart I don't know I and the other
release for me is anger and which I
would think is the same for you as well
you know you're in that situation where
your family really hasn't done anything
at all that warrants you being pissed
but your fuse is pretty short and it's
because you gotta you're dealing with
frustrations at work or anxiety about
your life or your career or whatever for
me a lot of times it's just this general
level of frustration and were the things
that we're trying to create
better and like creative aspirations
being you know restricted in some way
are thinking about are the future and
are we still gonna be relevant whatever
all those things that kind of get rolled
up and or maybe just you're just doing a
whole lot of things at once the stress
comes in and then it's got to find a way
out and so a lot of times with me it'll
just be an angry outburst not like
physical thing but just like a short
uncharitable tone or word with my kids
or my wife and so I'm I'm dealing with
that because a lot because the thing
that my therapist is trying to get me to
do is just be like okay when you are
experiencing something don't just
immediately move to what do you think
about it because I'm also a huge problem
solver and so if like if you even if
somebody tells me an issue that they
have emotionally I'm gonna the way I
respond to that is to tell you what you
should do or even if you know it's not
polite to say it because it you know
it's like in your mind or in my mind
it's immediately like well if it were me
I would do this my next step would be
this my action would be this and this is
problematic in relationships of Christ
so if your wife comes to you and says
that this is how I feel about this or I
had a bad day and this is specifically
what happened you know my typical
response is to be like well what are we
gonna do about it here's my advice and
what she's not interested in my advice
she's interested in me having some
empathy and feeling along with her yeah
now related to that one of the things
that I'm trying to do is sort of live
more in this part of my body like and so
again this is these are basically just
tools I don't think that I'm little or
some like center of mass of my soul that
is literally moving down to my heart but
there is this like physical like
question of like where do I feel this
thing and like how do i how do i embody
this on a more consistent basis so I
could be in a situation where I'm just
interacting with somebody and I could be
like don't just think about what they're
saying
think about this conversation feel what
they're saying and feel this
conversation and be in your heart and
you will be a more connected present
person yeah I'm you know we got an
advance copy of our friend Mike science
Mike McHarg new book which I'm sure
we'll talk about more later but price
shouldn't talk about his book which he
gave us a sneak peek but screw it he
said you know he's talking about how you
have a nervous system built around your
like your digestive system for example
yeah isn't it nerves aren't just to feel
at your fingertips but it's to give
feedback and if I'm not mistaken like
independent of like rational parts of
your brain like well I mean a lot of
your nervous system it just it works and
since signals in your body responds
automatically yeah but there's but
there's actually there's feeling and
sensation associated with these things
whether it's digestion or yeah there is
area there was a scientific reality to
it I I'm obviously I don't understand it
or can't explain it as well as Mike can
but it but knowing that is another
access point to I think what you're
talking about which is beginning to
awaken to the fact that everything
doesn't happen in our rational our
experience is not just limited to what
we can filter rationally that's what
you're saying right yeah and well and
also it's if you're like me you can have
a tendency to just come to the
conclusion that this is my personality
my personality is not very emotional
like I'm not one of those emotional
people there's not a lot of drama in
reality I'm just really good in certain
circumstances at behaving well but
because I'm a human that stuff that goes
in is going to come out in some form
like we discussed and
for me it's these unhealthy ways so all
that to say that sort of my mantra and
this is it's very difficult to remember
to do this
my mantra has just to be like being
begin the heart begin the heart you know
and and where does my hair and my beard
come come into this well but even that
is the that is the question but before
you answer that I actually what so if
that's your if that's your mantra the
thing that you repeat to yourself a how
do you do that and like what does the
mantra part mean and then what is that
what what what is the specific action
point what do you do to be in the heart
well I'm first of all I'm figuring that
out now one one thing I do is you said
mantra so first of all are you like
repeating over and over again that
phrase not outloud necessarily is it's
more when I find myself in a situation
I'm like how can I be more embodied
right now in this conversation in this
interaction in this moment whatever but
practically I think it happens in a
couple of ways one is asking myself what
do I feel about something as opposed to
just what do I think about it I think I
got enough thinking going on for like a
dozen people I don't you know I I i I'm
there's no I'm not about to think not
enough about something so it's more like
okay but what I can do and this is this
closes me off in relationship is to just
think about things and so it's like okay
what do you feel about that to actually
feel it take a moment to like where do
you feel it and what is the feeling I
mean a lot of times my therapist asked
me but no no what but what do you see
what do you do you feel about that I
might tell you I think about it so it's
asking that question now this the second
part of it I think for me a big part of
so kind of being present
in like a conversation is not and
especially in a cut in a group where I a
group maybe and not necessarily a large
group but where I tend to go into my
performance mode and this gets into a
little bit of the which we saw have
identify cast on this to India Graham
stuff which it's essentially just a way
to think about your personality it's not
particularly scientific but it's not
like astrology it's not it's it's just
based on observation and I tend to be a
performer and so I kind of adapt a
certain environment so it's like okay
I'm in this type of environment with
these type of people I'm pretty good if
figuring out very quickly how do you
succeed at being liked in this situation
like what kind of humor
what kind of conversational topics need
to be deployed in this conference in
this group to be seen as relevant a
leader just to perform well that is my
default really good at it but for me
it's saying okay you kind of break that
cycle of trying to perform and move into
a place that is more like not in for me
that's not filtering what I say now this
isn't you don't this is not your issue
you don't have a filter but I think that
that's a healthy thing in a lot of ways
you can get you into trouble and maybe
make you have to apologize more than the
average person but for me it's saying
like I'm actually going to say the first
thing that I feel about this thing that
we're talking about and I'm not going to
run it through the how does this fit
into my overall performance in this
setting now that's a vet happens quick
very quickly right and it's very
difficult to decipher between when is
this an authentic I'm just speaking from
the heart and just saying what I think
and when is this my sort of curated
thought because I'm so good at getting
to the curated thought my city quickly
from honesty versus speaking for a fact
yeah so I would say practically those of
the
two things I'm not saying that I'm good
at it so for the first one I'm curious
is there something I would maybe small
like an example of something where it's
like what was the mantra again how do I
feel about this be in the heart be in
the heart like can you think of a recent
example where it's like where you will
you redirect it in that way well I think
it happens more often in I think I'm
trying to apply it mostly in my
conversations with you know my family or
you know in talking to my mom I think is
a good example of like you know in her
recovery and then she's had a couple of
little setbacks with some things
unrelated to the the ankle that have put
her in the hospital I think she's gonna
be fine
but even in a conversation with her not
just being like okay my role here is
just the just the you know the
inquisitive concerned son mm-hmm
you know but again I'm not good at it
you know and going from the stages of
like I even go back before therapy I was
basically unaware that this was a
problem and now I've kind of moved into
an awareness that is a problem
but not necessarily an ability to always
act and change and I'm trying to move to
a conscious awareness where I'm actually
actively doing these things so that's
that's I don't know how long it's gonna
take to get there that's that's what I'm
working on but when you're on the phone
you're no longer just asking for like
the deep give me the update what is it
are you in oh you had to go back to
hospital what does the doctor saying
what's the next step what's the plan
okay let me know let me know when you
get the results or whatever right you're
trying to move beyond just the practical
yeah and it's not again it's not easy I
I'm not good at being well how like how
are you feeling about all this would you
think you pieces some as simple as that
is like entering into a real
conversation so I don't have a whole lot
of examples of like this is how I do it
because it's more just like I know it's
a problem and I'm trying to saw
the problem it's interesting because
it's compounded I would imagine in those
moments because it's it's a level for
someone who's like maybe this is this is
always coming easy to them and that's
not me either by the way but so someone
that's not either one of us that it
would come easy to again just like
empathy or like feeling someone's pain
is just something that just comes out of
them this is my wife but so for you it's
interesting that in making that effort I
think I would imagine there's a
roadblock and I guess I've experienced
this too that like there's an added
roadblock of a self-awareness that's
like there's a vulnerability to even
trying that makes it even more difficult
right it's like now all of a sudden I'm
gonna I'm instead of hanging up I'm
saying love you mom I'm gonna say how do
you feel or I'm gonna make the decision
to share how what she shared with me
made me feel I'm gonna share that with
her and then it's like I'm gonna do this
now and it's it's gonna feel weird to me
it might feel weird to my mom it might
like what's my my toe
what's my tone of voice when I start to
exercise empathy you know it's like I
would imagine because we think similarly
in this way that like we're so
self-aware that when we start doing you
start to engage those things that like
all of these signals keep saying well
it's not worth it right like even
something as simple as like what does my
voice sound like when I'm more
empathetic you know yeah I mean it's
yeah and I do think it's a separate
issue but yeah it's a compounding issue
but I think that it's just something
that is I think that our self-awareness
is what makes us good at what we do yeah
and it's why we can move into different
environments it's why we can host it's
why we can host a podcast the way that
we do is why we can host good mythical
morning yeah and it's
and I'm not you're aware of how the yeah
better we are the more we aware of how
every single thing strikes a viewer
we're pretty good it's stepping out and
observing exactly the way something that
we're doing would be interpreted or
understood or experienced by an audience
that's entertainment and while
simultaneously being in the moment as
much as possible which does require a
level of feigning it well I as a
performer I think that being a good
performer definitely works against all
of this mm-hmm you know what I'm saying
I think that the people who are probably
the best and the most embodied they
might be a great dancer you know and I'm
saying if you take something that she's
like this dancing oh you know what I'm
another I'm gonna go back to your
wedding again there I did a little
dancing at your wedding and not a lot
but you know but again I danced for show
hey you know I'm saying traditionally
yeah I move my body in a kind of a weird
way and I'm doing it kind of to
entertain people who were watching but
but I'm not dancing like nobody's
watching
and there's what is the dance Feldman
when everybody was circling your mom's
the mitts go disco so everybody starts
doing these concentric circles of that's
the horror the horror
okay the Horsham it's good that's the
crowning service and then or the
crowning ceremony when the parents the
last children of the parents are married
off they get crowned oh and the last
children of the parents are married off
they get crowned and everyone dances in
rent centric kisses them and then it
goes circles and then our DJ mixed it
into the hora and then he mix into the
hora but okay so it's a it was a
communal dance which by definition is
not about an individual's performance
and it's funny because I felt having
never done it there's this yeah I felt
the same thing that I think you're
describing which is like all
sudden were like linking hands with
people Christian and somebody I didn't
even know and then we're like doing
these consent I can see you on the other
side of the circle out of the corner of
my eye I know that you're probably
having a similar experience to me which
is like I'm doing this but I'm not
really giving myself over to it right
yes like I'm conjuring up the like I'm
I'm sending my pride aside that like
bless is about me what I will but I will
say that even in that moment I am doing
it more than I ever have I am I am
giving myself over to the joy of dancing
in a circle really and that's the
exercise yeah because yeah because the
natural inclination is well like if
there's a if the if the whole mob of
people on the dance floor form a circle
and then they want someone to go in
there and show what's up then it's like
oh there's an opportunity to perform
it's like yes I'm going to do that well
and I I'm a little I'm a little shy I'm
just a little shy in those situations
but then if the right opportunity
strikes I will go into the circle and
make a memory for people but the but the
giving yourself over to dance in a
communal environment like that and
that's why in these in I haven't been to
an embodiment workshop but an embodiment
workshop does involve you haven't have
doesn't fun it like freely moving your
body in a way that is without self
regard you know without self
consciousness in yeah it is all this is
all it is all related to what I'm kind
of dealing with in therapy and I do
think that our reputation
I don't know and again I think that this
is it's definitely issue for both of us
this isn't this is an issue for everyone
everyone has this like I am this kind of
person and I don't want to feel
uncomfortable and I don't want anybody
to make me feel uncomfortable everybody
has their own version of what that is
but I think in my family growing up it's
like we knew like we
we kind of prided ourselves selves on
you know being good at things and
seeming like we know what the hell we're
talking about and if we don't know what
the hell we're talking about we're
probably not gonna talk about it but we
think that we know a lot about a lot of
things so we're not talking about a lot
of things and it's like again I'm yeah
it's and then there's the opposite of
that which is just like this if you just
picture this like hippy just just moving
their bodies the music at Woodstock it's
like that purse now first of all because
you're humans and we all have egos
I understand how and this is what we're
gonna get into when we talk about my
hair in a second we finally get to my
hair and beard
the act of seeming like you don't give
up can actually become very much that
you do care a lot about how you're being
perceived because it's very difficult
for humans to parse that okay and it
might be difficult to decipher between
this person really is embodied and
doesn't care about what people think
about them they look exactly like this
person but this person actually is doing
this because they care about okay I
think I think yeah okay I'm starting to
understand where you're going so just
hit us with hair therapy oh the therapy
therapy that's what the hair opee
hit us with that okay in trying to find
other practical things that I can do to
reinforce this sort of direction that I
am moving as a person in the same way
that someone might wear oh I've got this
little rubber band that every time I see
it I think be in the heart you know
there's some kind of physical clue or
you know a a maybe a tattoo of a heart
something that helped on your heart no
there's a word for that but I don't know
exactly what it is
I think that
if i if i look at a picture of the
future me and it's the more embodied me
he has long hair and a beard and a long
beard why well you know you think about
someone who has thrown caution to the
wind and is sort of just trying to be in
concert with the forces of the universe
and is a member is a interdependent
member of the global community there's a
reason that you put you see somebody
with long hair and a beard and like okay
they're either homeless or Jesus you
know what I'm saying or or you're saying
enlightened no no no no no no I'm not
saying enlightened it by any means I'm
just saying that like they they kind of
look like they're not trying a whole lot
to like get everything exactly trimmed
up and combed in exactly the right way
to then get into the mold that people
expect but I also thinks if you're
saying grooming there's a reason that
there's a correlation between groom I
think it's pretty simple yeah I'm just
gonna state it simply if you go to
Woodstock you didn't see a lot of people
with buzz cuts and military-style
haircuts it was like long hair beard
hippie no bras it's a it's a relaxing of
standards and a relaxing of trying to
hold some sort of mold and fit into a
certain thing now again we'll talk about
how well they actually became the
counterculture became the culture in a
lot of ways and subcultures become
oppressive cultures that expect people
to do something to fit in rats are
simply a lack of like a loosening of
outward perceived grooming is it is is a
reflection of more of an inward grooming
like spending your energy on not what
other people perceive you externally but
how you perceive yourself
internally yeah okay yeah it's it's the
good is it's the just different than
saying you know I want to become I want
to become more woke I won't be like a
guru so I want to look like a guru yeah
if you're not saying yeah I'm not saying
that at all now that that is the
underlying reason now there's a but but
don't say but yeah just one more say so
and you got excited about that thought
because first of all it was you wanted
something physical that you could do for
yourself I think that and that's what
you came up well I think that I feel
like I'm in a pretty lengthy but very
purposeful personal transition been in
it for a while I hope to always be in
transition right but I kind of have a
little bit more last few years have been
the last decade has been pretty
interesting in terms of like figuring
out who is it that I'm that I want to be
like what what I want my life to be
defined by and I do think that some of
that has come in come more into focus in
the past few years and so I think that
this is just this feels like an in sort
of an alignment as you try to grab
things in your life and align them
towards something an outward sign of an
inward commitment yes like baptism we've
learned about growing up and now you
know I will also say that there are
because I am a person who's on camera
and I do care about my appearance I
cannot help but think oh but it's also
kind of cool to try something I haven't
done this I haven't grown my hair and my
beard out I want to see what happens
let's see what I can turn into
physically like a completely superficial
perspective that I'm not gonna lie to
you and tell you that though this is all
about embodiment and being in the heart
and that's why I want to look like I'm
at Woodstock no it's it's also it's kind
of I mean there's a reason that
it's kind of cool you look at those
pictures and let's people were kind of
cool right and so there's I understand
that that's that's the that is a
potential pitfall in this whole process
is that because it is about an external
thing and then that could become some
driving force and then I'm actually
trying to be cool or thinking that I'm
cool and then I'm kind of working as the
whole thing right can you have your cake
and smoke it too because if this was not
this is not about humility because I
think we're all very clear on the fact
that this is about humility I would
shave my head and shave my beard and I
would look like the end of a pencil like
an eraser and you know I don't have a
chin that's worth talking about and I I
just I would not look for some reason I
did that on my wedding day yes but I
didn't look good and it would not be
attractive to the average person and so
if I wanted to be humble I would do a
decimal more like a Buddhist tradition
right is to like shave it all off you're
kind of you're kind of you're dying to
yourself you're becoming more like this
other community there's less things that
distinguish you from another person so
the ego continues to die kind of I mean
this is something that's in many
different religions but I think the
Buddhists haven't figured out the most
and like this ego death thing right and
so that I am interested in ego death and
continuing to like tear apart my ego
that is a source of a lot of my problems
throwing out what beard and hair is not
going I'm not beaten right you might do
the optimum I'll do the office I I
greedy I think you're gonna look cooler
you know it's like it's someone who who
doesn't care but care so care so much
about could be caring so much about not
seeming like he cares that's cool and I
and in this town especially where
there's all types of people doing
different things physically and they all
look like they're trying really hard
even the people who look like they're
not trying like literally the only
people who look like they're not
crying are the homeless people to be
frank and sometimes you see somebody and
like Silverlake you're like yeah Helm
LeSueur hipster it's a game you can play
and macaws the fighters a fine line and
because you know the unkempt beard and
hair and ratty clothes can be something
like a cool thing in certain culture so
yeah so I'm a little I'm a little
nervous about that I will also say that
I cannot guarantee that there will not
be some other project or something that
we commit ourselves to that means that I
can't like let it keep growing that I
have to cut it for some reason I don't
know what that is
I have determined that like you know the
typical stuff that we do good mythical
morning whatever is not going to be
significantly impacted by me going my
hair and my beard out now I'm gonna
continue to get more food on my beard
when I eat and eating is a big part of
it you gotta get better at that you know
but I am trimming so I tried to just
send the mustache sideways but the
nature of my hair is that it's so wiry
and even with like the strongest
mustache wax I could find it quickly
goes back down so I will be trimming the
mustache is the only thing I plan to
trim for at least for a while like I'm
not gonna like try to be shaping the
beard into something that's like well
that guy goes and gets his beard trimmed
maybe I'll do that at some point but
this is really just about listen what's
gonna happen but you're doing it just to
recenter here and just to just to couch
the challenge that faces you you're
doing this in order to care less about
how you're perceived I would say that is
a secondary reason I think that this is
a physical manifestation of something
I'm trying to manifest internally which
is being more present more out of my
head and into my heart so as more hair
grows out of your head that's a reminder
I'm getting a little too technical
alright yeah it's not it's not like some
super I didn't like
go up to the top of the mountain and
wait for a sign I mean it it wasn't like
some I had a dream and it is to never
cut my hair again you know it that's not
what's going on it's just like hey
there's a few things lining up here but
I guess when you try it when you really
try to summarize it I'm trying to be
more like get more in touch with my
feelings or say it different ways like
be more like live more from my heart
than my head
therefore I'm letting my hair grow out
it's like and I don't if you just told
somebody that it wouldn't I don't I I
think I disagree with you because I
think that if you think about somebody
if you just talk about the idea of
embodiment and you use the example of
like what was and I realized that the
Cultural Revolution that happened in the
60s in the 70s was kind of rebelling
against conformity and societal
expectations and and that's why and
that's one of the reasons people were
growing their hair out because it was
like well men are not supposed to grow
their hair out so we're gonna do that
because this counterculture but I think
that that whole like Awakening and sort
of like being present and being in the
moment that kind of came with like
embracing some Eastern philosophies I
think there's a reason that you there is
a reason that you picture somebody when
you you see somebody with their like a
military style haircut that's like all
kind of like perfectly shaped and
clean-shaven and stuff like that that
doesn't say to you that's persons living
in their heart I'm not saying okay yeah
it's superficial okay and obviously you
can have no hair and be in your heart
yeah inward focus versus the outward
focus get a your own disposition yeah
and then so and then one example like
you saying a secondary thing of an
outward focus would be people's
perception of you so then the thing
given our line of work is that you're
gonna you're gonna get more feedback you
know having changed my hairstyle
drastically a couple of times you know I
weathered the storm of
vocative feedback it's like you it draws
more attention so it's like you're gonna
have to weather that and a lot of that
some of that will be negative like the
reason why I'm staying out of this is
because first of all it's not my place
to give an opinion this is this is
something that you know for obvious
reasons that we've discussed for 40
minutes but also I'm not opposed to it
because I don't think he's gonna make
you less cool but I could be wrong at
that point there may need to be an
intervention
but for now I'm you know I'm I'm I'm I'm
I'm quietly supportive from the
sidelines I don't know how I don't how
are you gonna weather the storm of in
increased scrutiny you know you can be
replying to comments you can be posting
selfies of beard progress I mean pop
potentially yeah that second on that and
I am replying to comments what are you
talking about right people's critical
comments I'm just saying it's if this is
an inward focus there's gonna be a
temptation because there's gonna be so
much oh yeah outward perception yeah you
might say why didn't you just let this
happen instead of talking about it well
it's like you're already talking about
it but but now what's the plan moving
forward biscuit ear are we gonna keep
talking about are you gonna post selfies
of your beard growth because that seems
that seems a little counter I don't
think I don't have to post selfies on my
beard growth because my beard growth is
going to be cataloged through all the
work that we do I was just giving it I
was given a working example of just
trying to highlight the challenge that
faces you well the more you want to
focus on where the people are gonna
focus on what you've done my friend I
don't hardly
I personally don't I'm not a huge fan
when people talk about things in the way
that I talked about it today I'm just
like just keep that to yourself brah but
the reason the reason that I'm talking
about it is because if we if I grow my
hair my beard out all the is something
there will be just lots of speculation
like oh they're got they have a project
in fact I've already seen it they have a
project and that's why I rest doing this
he's gonna be some character and
they're doing a lot of people thought
that my fake beard was back because my
real beard long especially with my
moustache kind of brushed out to the
side looked a lot like my fake beard and
some people like he's shaved is he
shaved his beard off yeah and it's like
don't if you're gonna speculate at least
you can know and maybe be even
supportive of what my actual reason you
didn't see any speculative comments that
went something like I bet this is an
outward expression of an inward reality
as a result of you know investing
himself in therapy yeah I didn't expect
that that's what I'm talking about it
yeah you're not seeing any day and I'm
also you know I'm a huge advocate for it
it's been you know I'm a huge advocate
for therapy for people who think they
don't need it because that that was me
you know what I'm saying it's for people
who are like I don't have an acute
mental problem or emotional problem or
even an acute trauma that I'm trying to
work through I'm just a person just a
human and I realized that therapy is a
privilege the fact that I can I can pay
for it I can afford it not everybody can
do that
I'm just saying that for me and it also
seems like the most Los Angeles thing
that you can possibly talk about is
therapy I get all that I grew up in
Buies Creek you know what I'm saying I
still understand what that's about but I
want because it's been so significant to
to tackle these things personally I just
want to continue to be an advocate for
it so I want to be open about I want to
be vulnerable but I want to talk about
the changes that are taking place so
somebody else can learn before they turn
40 but hey this stuff is very much worth
dealing with now I appreciate that so
when you see my long hair long beard
itself you can just remember yeah I
really appreciate you sharing that and
it makes it really difficult for me to
make fun of you but I'm still gonna try
also can you find me as the therapist I
just you know it's like it's not easy
yeah of course I haven't really tried
I mean I've you don't have to it's like
I'm very much in favor of it but it's so
such a daunting task to get off dime
I'm afraid that something I'm gonna have
to like I don't know something horrible
is gonna have to happen and for me to
say I have to get a therapist and that's
that's not I I don't want that to be the
case you can there's many different
resources that you can go and look at I
mean fact this wasn't gonna be my my
wreck oh let's go to a wreck
and I don't and make this it I guess
it's psychology calm which we've
actually I think we've used this several
articles from psychology calm you can go
on psychology calm go type in where
you're at and what you need and what
specific specific specialty you're
interested in and then therapist in your
area their profiles will come up and
there's like a little bit information
about them and then links to their
personal website if they have one and
their contact information including the
insurance that they accept so yeah and
I'm sure there's other resources again
this is not a sponsor this is just a
wreck and I actually recommended it to
somebody else recently and so I don't
know if there's a specific section for
that the website looks like it's from
nineteen freaking ninety-one yeah I mean
you got you know what you don't have to
be new school but yeah I think that
there is a therapist directory yeah yeah
therapists directory and like a lot of
therapists in your area will come up as
you do as you put in your information
and then you can the ones that support
you know take your insurance you can I
guess you can just call them or email
them and tell them what you're after you
can see pictures of people if you're the
kind of person that needs to see a
picture of someone and know what it's
going to be like to sit across from them
I had another wreck and I'll just save
that one save it man this is a good one
let's see what should my
therapist specialty be a DD addiction
adolescent adult aging agoraphobia I'm
just in the ACE yeah there's a lot you
don't even necessarily have to specify a
specialty yeah there's not I mean you
are an adult though you could just put a
dolt adult or you go to a children's
therapist I want to put a deal that guy
put adults I thought you went to a
children's therapist he also here he's
just family and kids as well yeah you
made a joke about something you're
actually doing alright hashtag ear
biscuits let us know what we got a title
this one therapy and what does therapy
have to do with rats hair I think it's
you know I appreciate the fact that we
had a growth suggestion well I'm not
going my hair out it was probably more
clickable it was I'm so glad this was
meaningful and not not just about your
hair actually oh what a relief
well thank you you know I'm proud of us
proud of you me too late alright I'm
really trying to feel I'm putting my
heart what do you feel right now I feel
feel like this is over yeah to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of your biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms thanks for being your
mythical best
[Music]